- Un air de déjà-vu.
Ce rond-point, comme ceux
que les gilets jaunes ont
régulièrement occupés, un peu
partout en France, au plus fort
de leur contestation, revit.
Sauf que c'est de la fiction.
Tout a été recréé, le temps
d'un tournage inspiré de ce
mouvement qui a secoué le pays
il y a quelques années.
(sirènes de véhicules d'urgence)
- Là, il faut deux figures.
Deux figures ici, la voiture
de police ici...
- Un court-métrage plutôt
qu'un documentaire.
TRISTAN TAVERNIER, co-réalisat.,
"Le mouchoir d'A
- Le mouvement des gilets
jaunes, il s'est un peu perdu.
Du coup, faire un documentaire
aujourd'hui, c'est un peu
autre chos
- Il n'y avait qu'à voir
la faible mobilisation lors
d'une récente manifestation
dans cette ville, Amiens,
l'une des plus pauvres
de France, frappée par des
délocalisations, des fermetures
d'usines; cette ville où
les gilets jaunes ont combattun.
- Ça symbolise plein de choses!
Voilà, voir le président, qui
est né ici, avec le gilet jaune
sur lui, avec l'oeil éborgné...a
sur le coeur l'utilisation
de projectiles en caoutchouc
par les forces de l'ordre.
Les blocages et les
manifestations, au départ
pacifiques, ont souvent été
émaillés de violence de part
et d'autre.
- En avant!
(coup de feu)
- Il attribue à la répression
et aux arrestations une partie
de l'essoufflement du mouvement,
qui s'était voulu apolitique,
avec des porte-parole, mais sa
têtes dirigeantes.
STÉPHANE FESSIER,
Gilets Jaunes 80
- Mais on n'est pas structurés,
on n'est pas aidés, on
de fric, on n'a pas des
secrétaires d'État, on n'a pas
même des secrétaires, des gens
qui gèrent pour nous. On fait ça
à l'arrache, avec des boutsdede,
on n'a pas d'armes, on ne fait
que des bouts de moyens avec
le temps qu'on peut, à côté
de nos métiers, à côté de nos
vies, à côté de nos enfants,
à côté de nos passions.
On met tout un peu de côté,
aussi, à un moment donné!
- Et quand, au soir du 10 avril,
Emmanuel Macron s'est qualifié
pour le deouououououour...
- J'ai pleuré. Mais j'ai pleuré,
sincèrement pleuré, parce que ça
fait quatre ans que je suis dans
la rue pour les gilets jaunes.
avavavavavavoir reculé sur une
nouvelle taxe sur l'essence,
l'origine de la colère, en 2018,
et du mouvement, Emmanuel Macron
n'a acquiescé qu'à quelques
autres revendications
des gilets jaunes, par exemple,
une prestation sociale
supplémentaire.
- Alors, on va dire :
on nous a balancé une cacahuète.
On a quand même eu ça et je sais
qu'il y a des gens pour qui ça a
vraiment été bénéfique.
Et du jour au lendemain, ils ont
touché 100, 150 euros en plus.
Pour nous, c'est beaucoup;
pour eux, c'est rien.
- Tous deux ne peuvent
se résoudre à voter soit
pour le président sortant
ou la candidate du Rassemblement
national, le 24 avril,
bien que 40 % des gilets
auraient voté pour Marine Le Pen
au premier tour, sensibles
à plusieurs de ses arguments,
notamment contre les mesures
anti-COVID. Cettutututututututut
l'une des figures de proue
du mouvement, va d'ailleurs
le faire, dimanche.
- Je regrette terriblement de
voir des copains gilets jaunes
appeler clairement... Alors,
je comprends le côté contre
Macron, mais appeler clairement
à voter Marine Le Pen,
parce qu'on n'aura rien de mieux
avec ça, avec ce parti-là!
- Il compte s'abstenir,
au deuxième tour. Comme bien
d'autres, plus question
de participer à un front
républican contre Marine Le Pen,
comme en 2017, ou contre
son père il y a quasiment
20 ans.
(cris de la foule)
Et pas question d'être tenus
pour responsables, si jamais
l'abstention devait favoriser
l'entrée de l'extrême droite
à l'Élysée.
- J'ai passé quatre ans à me
battre contre le gouvernement
Macron. C'est toute ma vie,
je me suis battu contre le Front
national. Moi, j'ai fait
d'autres choix. Donc maintenant,
les gens qui ont fait le choix
Macron-Le Pen, c'est à eux
de prendre leurs
responsabilités.
- Et aux gilets jaunes,
à réfléchir à la mobilisation
lors du prochain quinquennat.
Ici Anyck Béraud,
Radio-Canada, Amiens